hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
this week's q a sunday i'm going to be
going through all of your property
investment
questions and answering them off the top
of my head best i can
and listen while i'm doing this if
you've got anything blocking you
from becoming financially independent
through property investing
and you've got a question please do
comment your question below
and next week i'm going to be answering
your property investment
questions i really believe that the
thing that's stopping you from getting
from where you are to where you want to
go
is simply the answer to a question so
the better your questions are
the better these videos will be comment
below also don't forget if you haven't
already
i want you to smash the like button
there needs to be a blue thumb
up throughout this video i do q a videos
every single week and if you enjoy this
type of content let me know
by smashing the like button also don't
forget to subscribe because
i might answer your question next week
and if you don't subscribe and turn the
notification bell on
you won't even know that i answered your
question so let's have a look and see
what we've
got abdul azlam says do you need
planning permission to convert a single
dwelling
into two separate flats also would the
council tax change
once it has changed from one dwelling to
two flats and the answer is yes you will
need planning permission to turn a
property into two flats
and you're gonna get planning permission
by contacting the local council
and council tax will change because
instead of it being one property it's
now two
so the tenants assuming that you rent it
out or each have to pay council tax on
their new
apartment or flat because now it's two
properties if you're going to be paying
the council tax on the property it's now
two
so you are going to be paying two lots
of council tax but usually tenants pay
hope that helps what we've got next phil
carr send me a great content as always
i'm looking for some advice i'm
self-employed electrician living in the
liverpool area
looking to get into property with
savings and refinancing my property i
should have 150
000 pounds to start out would you buy a
house cash and implement the brr
strategy
and scale up or should i look at two to
three buy to let's not sure which road
to go down thanks in advance
so if you've got 150 000 pounds i would
probably suggest rather than buying
three or four buy to let's
if you do that your money is going to
have finished so you're going to buy
you've got 150 grand maybe three or four
buy tickets that's correct in liverpool
that would be the deposits and then how
much rent you're going to get
500 pound of each property minus
mortgage payments and expenses
you might be left with two three hundred
pounds so if you've got three or four
houses like that
you might be making a thousand pound a
month tops
so you're making a grand a month you've
got a few houses you've got mortgages on
them
that's okay but i would not do that if i
had 150 000 pounds
i would put it into a project i'd push
the value up i'd refinance
and hope to get all of my money back out
even if you just got most of it back out
and i'd keep doing that again and again
growing each time i did it to a bigger
and bigger deal
so that's my general guidance on that
question hope that helps
dylan harris samuel my plan was always
to remortgage my mother's home so i
could invest in property
i'm finally at the last stage of it just
waiting for the money to drop we'll have
around 135
000 pounds to invest in property my
question to you is
what would your next five moves be in
september 2020
in my situation to achieve financial
freedom as i am a single mother
p.s one day i will pass by your office
just to shake your hand again
just to say thanks for everything you've
put out into the world you're a big part
of my motivation you make
it easy to see the stars we should all
be aiming for
that's really sweet thank you so much uh
dylan i really appreciate that
um so you're gonna be refinancing your
mom's house september you've got about
135 grand and you want to know the
five things you need to do in september
jeez
um well i think the first thing i would
do is i would have a goal so
okay you've got 135 grand great but
what's your goal what's the plan what's
your
personal goal i think the second thing
that i would do is i would
tell people that you're gonna be
investing in property i would find a
success buddy
because when you speak it out you speak
into existence
it's amazing how many people you
probably already have in your life
that could open doors for you that might
have deals for you and opportunities
and connections but they don't know
you're looking for deals
so if you speak it out and say actually
i'm a property investor looking for
deals
it's amazing what doors and
opportunities can open so i would do
that and
find a success buddy as well find
somebody who
is on a similar path to you where you
can bounce ideas off each other have a
sounding board
third thing i would do is i would start
viewing some houses i'd start phoning
some estate agents and saying i'm
looking to get some deals i'm looking to
get some houses
and and throw the problem with them say
i've got 30 135 grand
i want to get the best return on my
money in this area
what you got and let them start showing
you around fourth thing i would do i
would get a mentor
i would get a either a property mentor
or get some training so that you
have because the thing is property is
the second best investment i really
believe the best is yourself so i'm glad
that the youtube videos have been
inspiring you
but i would get some serious training
because if you invest
a few thousand or even a few hundred
just into books and cds and seminars
believe me you're gonna make that back
in dividends because knowledge is power
um and then and then fifth i would if
you do those four things i would i think
then it's just down to you it's down to
just taking massive action
and saying you know what i know what i
need to do
i've told the world i've opened
opportunities i've set my
i've set my um goals um
i've now got a mentor i've got some
training so i can officially put
together not just a goal but have an
official business plan
now it's just a case taking mad action
doing things that most people aren't
prepared to do
instead of watching box sets on the
weekends going view houses instead of
scrolling on facebook and checking how
many instagram likes you've got
in the afternoon over lunch be phoning
up estate agents booking viewing so
that would be that was that was kind of
good actually i think that that
definitely deserves a like so smash the
like but that would be
my top off the top of my head five
things that you should do
starting in property hope that helps
okay who we got next a b
man samuel i want to be a millionaire by
26
have you got a plan i am 15 at the
moment
respect b-man i mean the very fact that
you're even watching my youtube videos
you're 15
and you're saying this is my plan i want
to be a millionaire
or 26. believe it or not a million being
a millionaire is not that impressive i
was a millionaire by age 25 so if either
by age 25 and i didn't really get
started until 17
and you're starting a 15 believe me you
can get there by 26 however
personally my best advice to you would
be this don't focus on being a
millionaire
focus on the the first step it's like
when climbing a mountain because what's
going to happen is if you're
if you want to be a millionaire and you
keep thinking millionaire millionaire
millionaire millionaire
and you start hustling you start doing
some deals
you're about to make a thousand pound
and then the deal falls through and
you're like i didn't make it
suddenly a million pounds can feel so
far away you can be like man you want to
give up you feel demoralized whereas if
you say
my first goal is i want to package and
sell a deal and make a thousand pounds
that's my first step of the mountain and
i'm just gonna do everything i can i'll
die if i don't do that
in the next three months not the next 11
years three months
make it happen and after a month you
package a deal and then it falls through
like i'm still i'm so close
you've got to you've got to feel like
you're close and then when you hit the
goal
then set the next one and the next one
and the next one keep taking small steps
before you know it you're on the top of
the mountain you're a millionaire and
then when you're on the top of the
mountain you're a millionaire then
you're going to realize actually maybe
i'm on the wrong mountain
maybe i didn't really do this because i
wanted to be a millionaire maybe i did i
did this because i want to help people
because i wanted to
but it doesn't matter because now you've
got the money and you've got the
experience of climbing you can then do
the next thing and go climb another
mountain so
that'd be my advice again if you're
enjoying this smash the like i hope that
helps
you man emma pembo i'm in the beginning
stages of my property career my chosen
strategy is rent to rent hmo
i have found i'm getting a lot of
rejection from landlords due to lack of
experience is there any
way of overcoming this i've included a
break clause in the contract but it
seems that this just isn't enough
reassurance i would love to know your
thoughts thanks emma
emma i'd i'd love to know how it's
coming up that you've not got enough
experience
are they asking you are they sensing
that you don't sound experienced and
they're saying have you done this before
and you're going
um um no because that you don't want
that
i mean i would flip the cards around
if doing a rent to rent and you've not
got experience i'd flip the cards
and if they start saying things like you
know you've got experience or how many
times have you done this before can you
show me some references i'd say you know
what i've just set the business up
but that's why i'm offering such a good
deal and this will be my first
contract but i'm i'm gonna do i'm gonna
do such a good job because my first one
on the condition that i can get a
testimonial off you how does that sound
you know you're flipping the cards
constantly and people can always feel
like they're disadvantaged and i'm not
saying
it's i'm not saying it's easy i've had
situations where i've secured rent to
rent and they pulled out because they
don't want to deal with a big company
they thought i thought you were just an
individual and now you're a big company
and i want to deal with you direct
so you can always flip the cards if
if you're a man woman black why if you
speak great english if you don't speak
good english
if you've got experience if you haven't
got experience if you're from a rich
family with lots of money or if you're
not you can always you always use it for
your advantage
and find a way to spin it that's what i
mean by flipping the cart spin it
to your advantage when you're selling
and this is all about sales
money comes from people money does not
come from property you've got to be able
to speak to people so
my probable assumption would be emma
that you're probably saying something
it's probably it's not that you haven't
got experience it's that
you're not filling the landlords with
confidence
so this is this is uh this is not about
your past this is about a present thing
right now how
you're gonna speak to the landlord hope
that helps uh abdullah
samuel i have a question how old do you
have to be to do a lease option
agreement
um i think i think probably 18 to do a
lease option agreement
although i mean i bought my first house
at 17 i just put it in a family member's
name so there's always a way around
stuff but
probably would imagine 18. samuel when
looking this is
jaboy by the way when looking for a brr
deal how is the best way to get quotes
from builders without paying them to
come out with you for reviewing haha
good question
so you don't know much about quotes
because
the real trick is you want to get to a
point whereby you can view a house
and you can kind of have an idea
yourself how much it's going to cost to
do it up
that's that's that's the plan and my
students i mean we've run a training
program called the
buy refurbished refinance master class
and on that program we go through how to
do that how to be able to price things
up
but if right now you're not there i
wouldn't say well don't view any houses
don't do anything
necessarily if you're not there i would
ask the estate agent say to the state
agent hey
this house needs a bit of work you some
for 100 grand how much direction it
would cost to do up
and they'll give you a bit of a ballpark
idea and put your offer based on what
they said
and then if it and then once the offer's
accepted get a build around
and then get a quote and then if the
quote's way off then you can say to the
stage and hey look
you told me to be about 10 grand my
builder's saying 20. so i need to
renegotiate with you right now
okay um brandon is there a way
to avoid capital gains tax by doing a
brr
strategy by refurbished refinance rent
also can you refinance from a
residential mortgage to a buy seller
mortgage
so firstly yes you can refinance from a
buy a residential to a buy to let
mortgage you'll need to speak to your
lender and you can do that
how do you avoid capital gains tax by
doing the brr strategy
that's the great thing about the
strategy you don't pay capital gains tax
because you don't pay tax you cannot pay
tax on debt
as much as the government would love to
tax you on debt
they can't so if you've got a house and
you push the value up and then you
refinance
that that refinance money is actually
although it kind of is profiting away
because the house has gone up in value
you're lending against that equity so it
is actually
debt because you're borrowing the money
against the new value
so you're not gonna pay a tax on it and
you can use that to go buy more houses
it's brilliant i know okay next reese
reese says rhys mckenzie samuel i'm 23
i now own my first property i'm looking
to buy a second property as a flip
project after studying property
development for 18 months part-time
as i am a building surveyor full-time
but require the investment funds for the
project where would you recommend i look
for these
okay great first thing great you've got
a house that's awesome
you've been studying property
development awesome so you're probably
reasonably knowledgeable
you are a building surveyor full-time
that's the same as my
wife i think she's a quantity surveyor
um was
not anymore your your problem is gonna
is gonna be getting money
um here's the thing a lot of the a lot
of these professional people like
yourself it's a massive advantage
um ben my brother-in-law he's been in
the construction business for 16 years
working really working really hard
working really well a lot of property
professionals are great at making other
people money
estate agents are a brilliant example of
that
they're great at helping make other
people money past deals to other people
um what you need to do is you need to
start now focusing on the money you need
to start getting good at money
you just start getting good at making
money and
my advice would be to start by raising
money you got to get good at sales
you've got to get good at sales speaking
to people showing them your skill
raising money i would just say from now
on you probably know more about
property and properties themselves
and development the most people which is
awesome
but knowing about property is not going
to get you rich so you need to think
right i need to
now i need to focus on how do i make
money how do i add value to people
myself
and extract money from them i mean it's
obvious you need to learn about raising
finance and joint ventures
that's that's that's that's the skill so
that i hope that's given you something
to think about if you want to ask a
follow-up question on that go ahead
by the way if you've got a question and
you've not asked it yet maybe you watch
my q a
sundays from time to time maybe you
watch them every week religiously but
you don't ask questions
now is the opportunity comment below
i'll be answering them next week
barris samuel love your videos can you
give advice on how to avoid or save on
capital gains tax both from a property
investor and by the little perspective
thanks a lot keep doing what you're
doing thanks
barris um how to avoid capital gains tax
well you can do a buy refurbishing
finance
so you can buy it and instead of selling
it you're only going to pay capital
gains tax when you sell the house
so you don't have to sell the house if
it goes up in value you can refinance
another way to save capital gains tax is
to move into the house if you move into
a house and do it up and then sell it
and you lived in there you're not going
to pay capital gains tax
so that that's another option hope that
gives you something to think about
okay mr chris i have recently been made
redundant
i have a property that is mortgage free
and the rental income covers the
mortgage on my home i live in
would you remortgage the property that
is paid off to buy more property or
leave it how it is
with it covering my mortgage i'm
hesitant to remortgage with lack of
experience and no other income being
financially free would be the end goal
so mr chris firstly you need to get
educated that's the very first thing
because
the reason you're a bit unsure and
confident is because you haven't got the
knowledge
that you need um that might not help you
right now but you need to set out on a
mission to get the knowledge
what i would do i'm not suggesting that
you do this
i don't know the exact facts but my my
gut feeling if i was you would be i'd
sell the house
i'd rent somewhere nicer upgrade
but then i'd use all that money from the
sale to go and invest in property really
smart
that that that's what i would do that's
what i do do
so but get educated get smart
put some of the money into into your
education i mean i know i'm like a
broken record saying this
but it's extremely important and i
realize it every day
how important it is when i see people
saying but you can just get the
information online for free though
and that's the by the way that's the
brainwashing from the government and
from the system that they say
you know don't don't not go to
university
because of course you can't get that for
free online
but but but don't go to samuel's
training or don't go in wealth creation
courses and learn about investments and
property
oh just you can get it online for free
because they know that you won't get it
online for free and they know that if
you do google it
you're going to get a whole bunch of
nonsense coming up so
actually when you invest properly in
yourself on the right training what
happens it's going to just set you head
and shoulders
apart from everybody else and you're
going to start flying as long as you
implement so
i hope that helps nadjum says
what happens if you take all these loans
and mortgages and accumulate all this
good
debt and you pass away well all the
money that you earned be used to pay off
your debt and nothing left for your
family to inherit if you pass away
great question um that's not that no
that won't be the case because
when you get good debt you you take that
good debt to go make money
so you you use the debt you don't just
take good debt and it does nothing
now yeah when you die that debt's gonna
have to be paid back but you've taken
the good debt you've used it to make
money and the money that you've made
is yours and when you die that will go
to your family and that will go back to
the bank
so you've got to see good debt as a tool
it's a tool to make money
i hope that helps sam e
i'm looking to buy a property to let but
i'm unable to get a mortgage in my name
due to my age i'm looking to get a
mortgage in someone else's name eg my
parents or grandparents or
partners parents how would i legally and
safely go about doing this what
paperwork is needed and how would the
person
that has the property in their name show
proof of funds sorry if this is
complicated
i'm just wanting to know exactly how it
would all work thanks in advance sam
speak to a mortgage broker and the the
thing that you need to know about you
need to ask them about what is
tenants in common that's what this is
called tenants in common
domerck just finished your football
event high i have a
large lump sum six hundred and fifty
thousand pounds after selling my
employees stocks
how would you use this to scale a
property business quickly but lots of
properties
buy lots of properties at once or a
couple at a time et cetera and refinance
and keep the cash
okay demerk this is actually an area
where i've changed my opinions over the
last sort of
three four years if you've got a big
lump sum 650 grand now i never had that
when i started out i started with
nothing and i slowly started building up
i probably wouldn't advise with 650
grand
to go and buy a load of little houses
because you're going to buy
little houses and you're going to have a
load of tenants and you're going to have
a load of
headaches basically now you might think
that sounds contradictory what do you
mean samuel i thought you can create it
to be passive income and systemize it
yeah you can
you can for sure but if you if you just
if you've got 20 grand or 50 grand or
you've got nothing
sure start with a small deal but once
you've got a lot of money
you don't want loads of houses because a
big deal takes just as much energy to
buy as a small deal so you're better off
taking that money and buying one big
deal
much less headache and and then buying
lots of small deals because every time
you buy a house you've got paperwork and
every time i tend
it it's not loads loads of hassle but i
don't want
hundreds of houses i used to but now
i've changed my strategy on that so if
you've got a big
look some i think how can you put that
into a big deal but of course
you've got to make sure that that you
don't lose it you don't get burned
so i hope that gives you some ideas and
some thoughts all right last one burning
desire
burning desire i can't work you out i
don't know if you're a troll
or if you're a general fan or what what
is what because sometimes you message
and say things like you know
i've even seen you on other people's
channels saying like samuel's a dick and
and things and then on my channel you
you message in and say
you know samuel here's a question and
then you get irritated i don't answer
your question
i think we just need to jump on a phone
call and settle this beef burning desire
but i tell you one thing though i do
appreciate that you do comment and
engage and this looks like a genuine
question to me so i will answer it best
i can
and let me know what's happening with
you burning desire i think i love you
maybe we've got a love hate thing i
don't know so burning desire says this
hi samuel i spoke to a property mentor
and asked if it's a good idea to have a
goal of buying five small houses at 75
000 pounds with a five
year period and getting them all paid
off 10 years from completion
they said i won't be financially free
from this do you agree that this is a
bad strategy
put me in the right direction please can
only afford to buy a house every two
years with 20
000 pounds and i don't want to save
forever
do you think once i bought these five
houses i can stop using wage to save up
much appreciated if you can finally
answer my questions again
so after so long i love watching your
videos
really are you sure i love watching
videos every day as they have value
okay um burning desire uh
my that is not a bad plan okay so if he
said to you that's bad
there's no i don't know if there's even
such thing as like a bad or a good
strategy per se
because everybody has got different
goals
has got different appetite for risks
so i'd never turn around and say to you
that buying a a house every two years
is a bad thing and i wouldn't say paying
off the mortgages is necessarily a bad
thing
i don't do that i don't want to pay off
my mortgages i'd rather instead of
saving to pay off the mortgages i'd
rather
save and buy more houses and have
leverage and have more cash flow and
have more capital appreciation when they
go up
so my advice to you i don't know if
you've got any problems yet
if you if you're in a position where you
can buy a house every couple of years
or has i can't remember exactly what you
said that's firstly great
you are in a better position than most
people because most people can't even
afford
to save anything that their wage is
two grand and their outgoings are two
grand and every month they just
literally that's what we call it the rat
race if i were you
i'd buy you buy a house i would
make it a really nice one i would
document it
i would make the make sure the figures
were good i'd then get a spreadsheet and
everything can show what the figures are
and i'd use that to show to a joint
venture partner
and if i were you i would then say
moving forward i'm not going to use my
own money moving forward i've used my
money once
now i'm gonna i'm gonna grow my
portfolio but i'm gonna get a joint
venture partner to put the money in and
i'm gonna show that i have the
experience because i've done this deal
here
and and even if you're only taking 30
percent but they're putting the money in
and you're taking 30 of the profit
it means you haven't got to save save
save save save to buy another property
so
maybe that would be some good advice for
you thank you for watching
folks i hope you enjoyed this please do
ask your questions below
don't forget to smash the like button if
that thumb is not blue and up
not down up up and below then we have
serious problems
um subscribe drop a comment thank you
for watching i'll see you next time
[Music]